if there was a mass looting on Fairfax
yes and
hundreds was totally fine would you be
offended if would I be offended all your
competitors
[Music]
so um
back during the riots that happened on
um like on Fairfax and Melrose yes I
remember you said something so uh
insightful about that when you were like
well we're the ones responsible for
placing value on these things right yeah
and I mean I think we have
responsibility in that for sure because
you have a store there right we do we do
yeah where is it on Melrose or Fairfax
we're on Fairfax just a couple blocks
south of Mount Rose
yeah so uh Melrose if you guys aren't
aware has been going through a ton of
like crime and uh the LAPD released a
safety alert just warning people not to
wear high-end jewelry when you go to
Melrose like when you're shopping or how
about police better what the [ __ ] dude
yeah hey don't don't go to a high-end
[ __ ] jewelry shop and like wear
jewelry
or go into a high-end jewelry shop and
be like and be like
they put it in your bag you know they
put in your bag and they're like yeah no
I'm good this place is expensive I have
to like role play as poor people to like
get your shopping done yeah oh wow wait
what for a watch are you guys out of
your [ __ ] mind thank you thank you
the funny thing is that if you don't
look rich and you go to these stores and
the employees just go can I help you I
judge you hey man they told me nothing
you know but if you show up just like
this they're like they roll out the red
carpet
oh wait till he comes out sir may I
offer you a charging station for your
hat
is it USBC or lightning
yeah so there's so there's a ton of
different robberies happening all the
time uh even the kids walking to Fairfax
High are getting like their phones
jacked just like yeah everything you
could think of
um what do you think about that current
state of Melrose because you've you guys
if you think it's just Melrose I think
it's La I think it's and then it's most
cities in the country it's San Francisco
too yeah it's Honolulu too right it's
Honolulu right so a lot of major cities
are it's definitely not just how I mean
my car got stolen last week not right in
front of my car it's the second time in
three years it's fully checked yeah like
a lot of like kids just pull up get out
they use you know they have like
amplifiers and they unlock your doors
and they put something up to the stream
where was your car Flash in front of my
house oh my God it's like so normal that
in the morning my neighbor was like your
car's stolen again and like again and I
know the whole protocol I have to go to
the police station father Port same guy
and then I have to submit that to BMW
just to locate the car because all the
cars have locators down now it takes
them a few hours of course you know and
then they're like it's here and then the
cops it's like a whole thing it takes
over your whole day then you have to
replace these which costs this is the
biggest scam in the world these things
cost like 600 now no instead of like we
used to just have these right like this
used to be your car key and this was
fine like I was okay with this right but
now they invent these which are like six
hundred dollars and they're they cost
like 20. it's gonna be a subscription
service for that get it for sure and BMW
is doing all these like add-ons whatever
I know we're completely I knew a guy
with an Aston Martin and he got the
Crystal Key which is like twenty
thousand dollars or something for for no
[ __ ] reason and he was at we were at
my friend's house and he loses the
crystal course he does yeah can't find
it anywhere we're all trying to look for
it but also I'm not really trying to
look very hard because I'm like [ __ ] you
getting the twenty thousand dollars
you see it over there you're just like
yeah yeah it's like when I'm looking for
something for Nikki like I'm always like
oh yeah no I'm just looking at all the
area around me I'm like yeah no it's not
here I don't [ __ ] know where it is
yeah it's not what I mean do you think
that the uh the police are are
responding well to the things going on
in the area no I think they're doing the
best job that they can I have a lot of
friends that are on LAPD force and you
know like they're up against the wall
too right so a lot of people got there a
lot of cops retired during the early
pandemic a lot of them were like I'm not
incentivized to be here anymore yeah
people blame the cops but it's really
the prosecutors not doing their job I
think there's like definitely an element
of that too I think there's it's like
super nuanced once you get into it and
then there's also an argument that this
has been going on for quite a while
right and like it's been accentuated
because of the last couple of years and
we're like scrutinizing it more and now
there's like more videos like watching
everything and I see every single
robbery that happens now and like
Jackfruit is just stuck in my algorithm
like anytime someone punches an Asian
person anymore I'm like oh my god there
was one that I was driving here and that
someone's a jackfruit was like does
anyone know this person and it's just
like a Latino guy that's driving that's
yelling at another did you see this it
just happened an hour before I got here
there's an Asian guy driving and he's
filming this Latino guy pulling up next
to me pulls his eyes back and he's just
like watch where are you going and
jackfruits just like does anyone know
this man and I'm like come on did I need
to see like that one happened that one
was almost comical right like I see that
like 400 times any Asian he's like come
on guys doing a bit come on yeah yeah
come on it's a character I'm not saying
it's good but we're so acclimated Asians
like I grew up seeing that where I'm
like oh my God we're gonna track this
guy down
like are we all gonna like we're gonna
catch him
I know because that's not the same as
beating up an Asian Grandma it's like
but they get treated the same it's like
dude what the [ __ ] Steve did that to us
when he walked in yeah I did it yeah
that's how I say good morning that's my
GM that's my GM but I I don't know I
think there's like systemically I think
there's so many things that have gone
wrong and are off the rails and like
we're all hyper aware of them you know I
think that there needs to be a lot of
Correction and things improved and
there's like most of what I would say
even back during the riots was just the
wealth disparity alone and like the
Haves and the have-nots I think that's a
really significant issue that needs to
be explored and addressed and that's
like that's I try to address that a lot
bring it up a lot you know like there's
a reason why a lot of these things are
happening and you can't blame a lot of
people without means for wanting to
steal things that you're constantly
dangling in front of them being like you
can't have this right like Jerry
Seinfeld and kit it's really cool but
how does it feel to someone who will
never have that and you're like you'll
never be enough unless you have this
you'll never be as cool as this yeah
they can only take so many generations
of that before they're like you know
like [ __ ] this like this sucks I'm never
gonna be set up for Success can't they
just get some kith socks though and be
happy I don't know I'm sure kids
thoughts are like 150 dollars which is
outrageous [ __ ] crazy right like this
is the nature and that's really like the
overarching statement of what I was
saying was like we all participate they
don't participate in this it's called
veblin Goods which is like you're
essentially making something expensive
just because right and then that makes
it cool and it's not necessarily this
doesn't cost 600 to replace but it's a
status symbol for me to have it and so
we're constantly indoctrinating young
people especially in consumers to say oh
I need to spend this month much just to
keep up with the Joneses and to feel I'm
of value and it's not real I mean
Jordan's bro like look at all the kids
who like waiting for Jordan yeah and
people like get killed or they get into
a lot of fights over that stuff and it's
like can you really be that surprised
when we architect marketing and branding
to put people into these positions and
then where they're forced to do that
who's the basketball player who came out
with cheap shoes and all the kids sort
of naked for the kids jacket from
Payless they made like 20 30 shoes hey
[ __ ] your Shaq shoes it's like yeah
like to like solve it yeah yeah because
accessibility people see it as cheap
yeah exactly when it's for everyone then
it's like all of a sudden not valuable
because anyone can get it there was like
and I talk about this a lot but in
Street where in the early days the whole
point of Street where it was you wanted
to wear something that nobody else had
right and you want to feel special
because that's fashion was being heavily
commodified by Old Navy and GAP and
everybody was in khakis and there was
people like us that were like I don't
want to be just like the rest of the
people in khakis I want cool baggy denim
or do I buy that and so streetwear was
set up in a way where it was like there
was a scarcity of goods but it wasn't
about how expensive it was it was just
geographically Out Of Reach so it's like
you can still get it but you actually
had to try you had to like go on to the
right message boards you had to know the
right person you had to like be involved
in the culture know a guy know a guy no
girl that gets you into the store and
then they would validate you and then
you would actually be able to buy the
pants and so there was like you could
actually earn it and it wasn't about you
were priced out but then the internet
happened and then all that stuff ended
up being accessible to everybody and so
the only differentiation of whether you
can get something or not was how much
you priced it at and so then streetwear
went from being to me more about for the
people and for the culture to like are
you rich enough to be able to afford
this and it's not even designed well
it's just it's expensive which is again
the bevel and goods thing which is which
is what nfts half of nfts like that too
nfts and art and luxury goods and the
luxury market and a lot of what we do
now it's like is that coffee necessarily
better than McDonald's coffee was fine
when we were growing up and now there's
like a 10 coffee that you're supposed to
drink a cafe yeah I would say that in in
human nature though everything has that
Evolution cycle so for example all
Rebels become institutions right so like
all Rebel groups which is like a Counter
Culture group or whatever they'll take
over they'll become the dominant group
and then they'll become the Old Guard
and then a new group has to form to
break that so it's like
it's also like a sign of Youth right to
be rebellious like streetwear was
rebellious or subculture counterculture
yeah being Punk whatever what all
becomes commodity uh Commodities or
whatever yeah [ __ ] Kamala
commoditized because it gets arrested
for a minor drug infection the people of
that subculture become older and they
need to pay bills like hippies yeah like
all like and this happens inside and
they want to turn that back to the
future love into a Back to the Future
business right right yeah like like the
Surfers they they were lower they were
the first real counterculture yeah and
then they they turn it into a business
you know it's all consumerism and like
having this conversation the other day
because someone was talking speaking of
like being involved in activism and
social justice when I was in high school
someone's like how'd you get it or were
you always this way and I was just like
yeah when I was 12 years old 13 years
old I was going to Black Panther rallies
because at that time that was a real
subculture and it was this really
subversive effort to be involved in
these movements and it wasn't cool or
mainstream to me into politics at all
most people in the 90s like the 90s
generation really didn't stand for
anything like Woodstock was kind of like
the biggest social movement of its time
which wasn't just like Limp Bizkit and
people moshing in mud well we had we had
Nickelodeon as a big help yeah yes oh
yes we were crushing that so to be
involved in like to be hyper aware of
politics was like you were like a real
outlier yeah that's true right but now
to be involved in politics and social
justice and activism it's like so
mainstream and now like it's expected
and every celebrity every Big Brand does
it and so it's always puts me into a
weird position where I'm like I'm really
interested in stuff and I think it's
important but the way that a lot of it's
playing out is like through signaling or
you know it's being corporatized or it's
being sold as like a product and I'm
like that's such a weird relationship to
have with activism social justice to
where now it's almost like a logo you
wear that's right and there's literally
brands that are built around like the
name of the brands are about like being
socially aware and I'm like that's cool
but then it's also like really counter
to the ethos and like the the spirit of
what it's supposed to be because then
you can you're conflating Commerce and
money with actual like I'm doing things
because I believe in it you know or
because I want it I remember seeing
celebrities at award shows like in the
90s for example or 2000s and they're all
wearing ribbons and [ __ ] like for
whatever cause and I remember like
thinking like
okay so that's what they're doing
they're wearing it on camera so to them
they're doing something about it and
that was kind of the early pre like
virtue signaling that we all have on
Twitter now I retweeted a bunch of [ __ ]
I'm the [ __ ] man today I did a lot
today for this [ __ ] but I think I did a
lot today you're tired the material
version of that like that we had growing
up I saw that a lot and I remember
thinking how weird that was like that
means you've done something for it hey
we're spreading awareness we're doing
something here my last my last final
question is if there was a mass looting
on Fairfax yes and
hundreds was totally fine would you be
offended if would I be offended I had
competitors
some of the stores on Fairfax did get
looted ours wasn't touched for a number
of reasons but
um I mean sure like I'm like okay guys
the door's open
we got good [ __ ] real good [ __ ] it's
expensive real expensive how the [ __ ]
did Ross get taken
foreign
[Music]
[Music]